[Musique]
et on commence cette émission avec
Valérie Boyet bonjour vous êtes donc
sénatrice les républicains des bouches
du rô on va commencer par évoquer la
crise agricole et le drame de Pamier
hier une agricultrice et sa fille sont
décédé dans un accident renversé par une
voiture sur le barrage d'agriculteur de
Pamier ce drame il met encore plus la
pression sur le gouvernement que doit-il
que doit annoncer gabrial pour calmer la
colère des agriculteurs d'abord je
voudrais dire toute la peine immense
comme française que je ressens
aujourd'hui pour ce qui s'est passé à
Pamier c'est absolument abominable euh
cette femme cette famille qui était là
pour dire on veut vivre dignement de
notre métier notre métier est une
passion on aime nos bêtes on aime la
nature euh j'ai toujours voulu faire ce
métier qui a choisi de passer la nuit
sur un barrage et qui était en train de
se restaurer avec son enfant de 12 ans
et elle meurt euh parce qu'il y a eu un
accident de voiture par des personnes
qui n'auraient jamais dû être là c'est
ça la le je dirais c'est un drame dans
le drame qui signe quand même la
puissance de fr des personnes des
personnes de nationalité arménienne qui
étaient sous obligation de quitter le
territoire français puisque leur Rael
semble-t-il avait été rejeté pour le
droit d'asile donc on voit bien qu'on
qu'on est un petit peu à la convergence
de toutes les impuissances que l'État
Macron organise aujourd'hui sur le fond
de cette crise agricole euh qu'est-ce
que propose la droite pour y répondre
est-ce qu'il faut stopper toutes les
normes environnementales contre
lesquelles et bien manifestent les
agriculteurs d'abord je pense qu'il faut
que les Français se rendent compte que
aujourd'hui au Parlement européen il y a
un double langage de la macronie d'un
côté ils disent en France moins de
normes on vous en le discours de Gabriel
atarle sur les écologies était parfait
sauf que dans la réalité lu la la tous
les macronistes il y en a pas un qui a
manqué à au Parlement européen ils ont
tous voté pour Pascal campfin qui est le
président de la commission environnement
à l'Europe donc un écologiste qui est
devenu macroniste euh pour justement
mettre toutes ces normes baisser le
revenu des agriculteurs faire en sorte
qu'on cultive moins de surface nous
sortir de la de la souveraineté
alimentaire quand vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui les Allemands
produiraient plus de fraises qu'en
France que un poulet sur deux vient de
l'étranger en France mais jusqu'où
va-t-on dans l'absurdistant qui est le
nôtre aujourd'hui que le revenu des
agriculteurs qui est déjà le plus faible
en France est encore aggravé parce que
les macronist vote au Parlement européen
et ser rise sur le gâteau on nous dit
oui nous on veut préserver nos
agriculteurs et cetera mais Monsieur le
Maire le le ministre de l'économie il
est pour la viande de synthèse à un
moment donné il faut arrêter et
d'ailleurs au Parlement européen la
droite européenne le Parti populaire
européen avec un parti d'ailleurs auquel
appartient les républicain et bien cette
droite européenne a soutenu les accords
de libre échange qui ont été signés par
l'Union européenne et ces accords ils
sont dénoncés par les agriculteurs
aujourd'hu
att au Parlement
européen nos députés menés par François
Xavier Brami n'ont pas voté ces mesures
ils se sont opposés aux mesures que je
viens de vous décrire les mesures qui
sont soutenues par les macronistes et
par Pascal canampfin et les accord de
libre échange qui sont alors sur les
accords de libre
échange et bien je pense qu'il faut être
là aussi cohérent on a des accords de
libre échange qui musellent
l'agriculture française comment les
Français et d'ailleurs il y a eu un
sondage qui est paru où 95 % des
Français sont contre le fait qu'on mette
dans les dans les étales français des
légumes des fruits de la viande qui est
fabriqué par par des pays qui ne
respectent pas nos normes aujourd'hui on
demande aux agriculteurs français de
boxer les mains dans le dos c'est-à-dire
qu'on leur impose des normes qui sont
toujours plus plus écolo et cetera
pourquoi pas moi je suis pas contre mais
pourquoi à ce moment-là on importe des
des fruits et des légumes maintenant on
a même plus un fruit sur deux je crois
vient de l'étranger on importe des
fruits des lécunes qui ne sont pas
fabriqués dans les mêmes conditions
c'est antiécologiste en tout point et
c'est de la concurrence des loyoles qui
est organisé regardez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pour la pêche pour la pêche
on on contraint les pêcheurs à ne plus
pêcher ce qui est quand même dramatique
alors qu'on a la pêche la plus oui enfin
France mais dans les eaux territoriales
françaises mais pendant ce temps on va
importer du poisson qui est pêché dans
des conditions écologique déplorable qui
vient de loin et où on se préoccupe pas
de savoir si les dauphins et autres
poissons sont protégés donc on voit bien
que c'est l'absurdistant et les
agriculteurs n'en peuvent plus surtout
que aujourd'hui ils craquent parce que
on on va leur enlever les les avantages
qu'ils avaient sur le gazoil une
dernière question de sécurité après le
drame de Pamier est-ce que le ministre
de l'Intérieur Géral darin doit procéder
à l'évacuation de tous ces blocages tous
ces barrages d'agriculteur sur les
routes je pense que le gouvernement doit
arrêter de souffler sur les braises
qu'il a lui-même allumé parce que c'est
de ça dont il s'agit aujourd'hui
éacu il faut donner une réponse à ses
agriculteurs une réponse qui est digne
ils cassent rien les agriculteurs en
revanche quand ils sont victimes des
écolosadistes à s Soline ils sont pas
très soutenus qu quand les adistes
bloquent des routes quand les adistes
bloquent des routes on les évacue endez
les AD ils ne se contentent pas de de
bloquer des routes ils détruisent ils
insultent ils rentrent dans des
propriétés privées là les agriculteurs
ils disent nous voulons vivre dignement
de notre travail vous ne pouvez pas
organiser notre perte moi franchement la
France en France tous les gens qui sont
nés en France et en France
métropolitaine en particulier ont eu un
ancêtre paysan la France ce sont les
paysans moi je n'oublie pas le mot le
beau mot de fer de Fernand brodel pays
paysan pays paysage aujourd'hui
organiser la casse de l'agriculture
française qui est la meilleure du monde
qui est la plus écolo du monde c'est
j'allais dire marquer un but contre la
France et il faut arrêter je pense qu'il
faut répondre à cette souffrance il y a
27 exploitations qui ferment par jour en
France alors Valérie Boyer aujourd'hui
la souveraineté alimentaire est menacée
c'était l'agriculture a qui participit à
l'excédent de la la dépense de la
balance commerciale et aujourd'hui on on
on importe des légumes qui sont faits
dans des fruits et et de la VI qui est
faite dans des conditions déplorbl voyer
on va parler de l'IVG puisqueaujourd'hui
on stigmatise nos agriculteurs je pense
qu'il faut vraiment arrêter c'est une
souffrance qui qui doit cesser
aujourd'hui l'Assemblée nationale
devrait adopter le projet de loi qui
prévoit l'introduction dans la
constitution de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse un texte qui
ensuite doit être adopté dans les mêmes
termes par le Sénat et hier le président
du Sénat jardarché et bien a émis une
fin de non recevoir il s'oppose à cette
réforme de la Constitution pour
renforcer le droit à l'avortement Jard
Larché a raison d'enterrer cette réforme
bah il a entièrement raison d'abord je
ne comprends pas pourquoi le débat
américain s'impose en France en France
personne personne ne remet en cause
l'IVG personne que ce soit de l'extrême
droite à l'extrême gauche tout le monde
est d'accord en revanche je vois que
sous la macronie on a fermé 130 centres
qui s'occupaient de l'IVG pour l'accueil
des femmes aujourd'hui nous avons en
France un équilibre cet équilibre c'est
celui de la de la loi veille qui prévoit
la préservation du du droit des femmes
et puis après une certaine date la
préservation du droit de l'enfant et de
l'enfant à naître cet équilibre doit
être est menacé aujourd'hui et euh il y
avait une sorte d'accord sur la liberté
parce que l'IVG n'est pas en un droit
c'est une liberté et là Emmanuel le
droit de l'enfant à naître est en danger
aujourd'hui non non c'est par ce que
j'ai dit j'ai dit que la loi veille
préservé en fonction de le droit des
femmes et puis ensuite après une
certaine période qui est la période où
on peut avorter et celle où on ne peut
plus le droit de l'enfant à nêord la
différence entre bon on va pas faire le
débat sur l'IVG tout ce que je dois dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas menacé
ce sont les conditions dans lesquelles
les femmes sont accompagnés qui sont à
revoir on a fermé 130 centres en 10 an
donc sous Emmanuel Macron euh qui
s'occupé de l'ivsg et aujourd'hui ce
texte dans la Constitution qui n'a aucun
sens et qui est pas utile va ne va pas
améliorer la situation des femmes ne va
pas ne va pas l'améliorer c'est pas
possible il y a rien qui est prévu pour
ça et ne va pas garantir non plus mais
en enterrant cette réforme
constitutionnelle pour renforcer l'IVG
dans la Constitution est-ce que est-ce
que les est-ce que les sénateurs les
républicains ne tombent pas dans le
piège de la macronie c'est-à-dire
apparaître comme un parti un peu
rétrograde au du point de vue de
l'opinion car l'opinion est pour non non
l'opinionber dans l'opinion est pour
qu'on accueille mieux les femmes et pas
qu'on ferme 13 centre l'opinion est pour
qu'on qu'on qu'on préserve la santé des
femmes aujourd'hui celles qui
choisissent d'avoir une IVG et qui
doivent être suivis également puisque je
rappelle que c'est sous sous la gauche
qu'on a supprimé la notion de détresse
alors peut-être qu'il fallait l'appeler
différemment mais en tout cas il faut
organiser le suivi de ces femmes hein
procéder à une IVG c'est pas n'importe
quoi en revanche si comme le souhaite
Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui après avoir
tergiversé euh il donne une liberté
garantie c'est-à-dire qu'il crée un
droit opposable à l'avortement non
seulement ça va pas améliorer la
situation des femmes mais ça reste ça ça
va en plus créer des difficultés
puisque'aujourd'hui il y a une clause de
conscience euh qui s'applique aux
médecins qui ne sont pas obligés de
pratiquer l'IVG enfin qui qui s'il ne le
souhaitent pas mais les femmes ont
toujours le droit ce droit est préservé
écoutez on a tellement de débats en
France qui sont utiles qui sont urgents
etmanuel Macron a refusé une réforme de
la Constitution il procrastine a
procrastiné pendant plus d'un an sur
l'immigration
just ref que les Français appellent de
leurs vœux et là on aurait quelque chose
d'inutile un catalogue de droits sociaux
qui va encore diviser les Français sur
une question POS pas en France on va
évoquer d'autres débats Valérie Boyer
l'immigration dans quelques minutes et
puis le débat qui était au programme du
Sénat hier la lutte contre le terrorisme
on accueille notre journaliste
parlementaire Steve
[Musique]
Jourdan bonjour Steve bonjour Alex
bonjour madame la sénatrice alors Steve
hier les sénateurs examinent une
proposition de loi les républicains pour
renforcer la lutte contre le terrorisme
oui c'est un texte déposé après
l'attentat de Paris au mois de décembre
on s'en souvient ce jeune homme
d'origine iranienne de 26 ans qui avait
attaqué au couteau et au marteau des
passants aux abords de la Tour Effel il
avait déjà été condamné pour un projet
d'attentat terroriste première fois
qu'un condamné passe à l'acte en sortant
de prison c'est un profil qui inquiète
particulièrement les autorités Alex ce
chiffre depuis l'été 2018 486 détenus
islamistes ont été libérés parmi eux
près de la moitié serait encore c
radicalisé hier Géral Darmanin a fait un
point sur le niveau de la menace en
France écoutez sont souvent des Français
ou des étrangers qui sont depuis
longtemps sur notre sol inspirés ou
influencés par la propagande djihadiste
qui sont les plus enclin à passer à
l'acte des terroristes de l'Intérieur
agissent souvent de leur propre chef et
depuis 2018 sont très autonomes
vis-à-vis des mouvements terroristes
connus changement radical par rapport à
ce que nous connaissons jusqu'à présent
et Steve les sénateurs veulent muscler
le dispositif de surveillance des
terroristes qui sortent de prison oui
aujourd'hui les terroristes qui sortent
de prison et qui sont considérés comme
dangereux peuvent faire l'objet d'un
suivi spécifique c'est ce qu'on appelle
des mesures de sûreté elles sont prévues
par une loi adopté en 2021 plusieurs
obligations peuvent être imposées comme
le devoir de pointer au commissariat la
nécessité d'obtenir l'autorisation d'un
juge pour changer de résidence ou encore
l'obligation de porter un bracelet
électronique mais les sénateurs
souhaitent aller plus loin écoutez la
mesure de prévention de la récidive
terroriste réemment mise en place n'a
pas tellement abouti n'a pas abouti
d'ailleurs nous avons donc souhaité
réintroduire une mesure hybride déjà
votée par deux fois dans cet hémicycle
mlant suivant mant suivi et surveillance
judiciaire et au critères de prononcer
plus souple très concrètement deux
nouvelles mesures de sûreté sont
demandées par les sénateurs la rétention
pour les condamnés encore engagé dans
une idéologie radicale ou encore la
rétention en raison de troubl psych que
grave Alex et puis le Sénat demande
aussi de moderniser notre arsenal pénal
oui il s'agit de s'attaquer au loup
solitaire ce qui se radicalise seul sur
les réseaux sociaux les sénateurs
demandent le retour du délit de recelle
d'apologie du terrorisme qui avait été
censuré par le Conseil constitutionnel
ça consiste dans le fait de détenir des
fichiers contenant des appels au passage
à l'acte il demande les sénateurs
demandent également la possibilité de
prononcer des peine de bannissement
numérique pour ceux qui appellent à la
haine sur les réseaux ou encore la
création d'une peine d'interdiction de
paraître dans l'espace public bon pour
la gauche tout ça c'est très très bien
mais est-ce vraiment efficace écouter la
grande majorité des articles que vous
proposez ne résolv même pas les
problématiques que vous-même avez défin
avez posé et essayer de résoudre par ce
texte pour l'ajouter un 1 texte plutôt
sécuritaire mais qui ne va pas avoir de
réel impact sur la résolution des
problèmes que vous
souhaitez toucher Mad la sénatrice
emmanu Macron demand de faire moins de
lois il parle d'inflation législative
cette loi elle est vraiment nécessaire
en l'état actuel c'est vraiment une
urgence aujourd'hui bah je pense que
c'est difficile de ne pas répondre à
l'inquiétude qui est la nôtre qui est
l'inquiétude des Français à savoir que
ces personnes ont purgé des peines et
que maintenant elles vont sortir on pas
parce que c'est de ça dont il
s'agit pas on n'est pas on n'est pas
dans une dans dans un crime ordinaire
avec quelqu'un qui va peut-être changer
et cetera on est là dans des personnes
qui veulent enfin détruire notre société
qui font l'apologie d'une idéologie qui
n'est pas la l'autre qui est mortifère
donc il faut trouver des moyens pour se
protéger je rappelle que la France a été
le pays de d'Europe occidentale le plus
touché par les
attentats islamiste donc il est
impératif que pour le terrorisme qui
n'est pas quelque chose d'ordinaire
qu'on puisse trouver des solutions c'est
une approche on va voir ce que le texte
va donner quand il reviendra de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a une
question de temporalité parce que cette
protection jusqu'à quand Jordan bar
bardellaa nous dit que la
déradicalisation de ces gens n'est pas
possible vous êt d'accord avec ça d'
d'abord Jordan bandena AA pas la vérité
révélée sur sur tous les sujets euh la
déradicalisation n'est pas possible
c'est pas plein de personnes le disent
et c'est toute la difficulté pour
justement pour le terrorisme et c'est la
raison pour laquelle on cherche dans un
état de droit qui n'est pas un état de
faiblesse des moyens de nous protéger et
de protéger et de protéger les Français
d'une récidive c'était tout le sens de
ce que nous avions de ce qu'on a voté
hier merci beaucoup Steve pour toutes
ces explications et on se retrouve tout
à l'heure dans le club des territoires
on parlera de de Gabriel àal dans le
Chauderon l'Assemblée nationale face à
la colère des oppositions et des
agriculteurs merci beaucoup Steve Valéri
Boyer on va évoquer la loi immigration
puisque demain c'est une date importante
hein le Conseil constitutionnel doit
rendre son avis sur ce texte et il
pourrait retoquer plusieurs
durcissements du texte qui ont été
ajoutés par les sénateurs les
républicains comme le durcissement de
l'accès aux aides sociales pour les
étrangers au regroupement familial ou
encore la remise en cause du droit du
sol en cas de censure du texte par les
sages du Conseil est-ce que ce serait un
échec pour les
républicains non les républicains ont
fait les républicains ont demandé à ce
que ce texte soit voté ils ont fait
voter le texte euh ils ont fait voter
leur texte enfin notre texte hein qui
est euh a abouti puisque je le disais
tout à l'heure Emmanuel Macron sur ce
sujet comme bien Drut à procrastiné mais
on voit bien la duplicité du président
de la République qui demande à sa
majorité de voter le texte pour en même
temps euh saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel et en même temps ne rien
dire et être muet sur le fait que nous
avions un un Pierre Moscovici qui a
retenu un rapport qui allait dans le
sens de la nécessité absolue celui de la
cour des compte alors que son travail
c'est d'éclairer le débat de faire en
sorte queon arrive à aboutir sur
l'immigration l'immigration est en train
de fracasser tous les domaines de la vie
française l'immigration légale ou
illégale on voit bien la ulté qui est
l'anneau détournement du droits d'asile
sur représentation de l'immigration dans
le chômage dans la délinquence dans
toutes les difficultés ça coûte des
milliards et des milliards aux Français
la crise du logement dont on va on n pas
le temps de parler ce matin mais qui est
largement aggravé par l'immigration donc
à un moment
donné on ne peut pas continuer comme ça
c'est une réalité donc sur ce domaine
comme sur les autres on peut pas avoir
un double discours tout à l'heure on a
vu le double discours de la macronie sur
l'agriculture là on voit le double
discours de la macronie sur
l'immigration et la complaisance de la
gauche enfin on peut pas aller de de de
lutter contre la préférence nationale
pour arriver jusqu'à la verersion
nationale parce que c'est de ça dont il
s'agit aujourd'hui donc moi j'espère que
le Conseil constitutionnel va être
raisonnable et va examiner ces Tex de
toute façon quoi qu'il arrive nous nous
souhaitons une modification de la
Constitution pour qu'on reprenne la main
sur ce sujet et un référendum voilà ça
c'est une c'estd que le texte
fondamental de notre République ne nous
permet pas de de gérer pas toujours
puisque nous sommes soumis à des textes
européens et là on va bien voir ce que
les macronistes votent en France et ce
qu'ils votent euh à l'Union européenne
on il faut qu'on
s il faut il faut se libérer de ce
carcan dans lequel on nous enferme
aujourd'hui tous les pays cherchent des
solutions certains pays en trouvent
certains se dédouinent euh sortent par
exemple sur un autre sujet l'Espagne et
le Portugal sont sortis de certains
textes pour l'énergie ils s'en portent
pas plus mal hein ils ont pas été ét
sanctionné d'autres sur l'agriculture
beaucoup sur l'immigration aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas rester dans cette
situation qui est une souffrance pour
les français et qui est aussi une
souffrance pour ces migrants à qui on
promet l'Eldorado qui ne trouvent pas et
et qui sont dans les mains de
trafiquants d'êtres humains moi je pense
qu'il faut arrêter je vais vous prendre
un exemple rapid après on va aller voir
parten de la Marse les mineurs non
accompagné euh qui peut croire
aujourd'hui qu'ils viennent tout seul
qu'ils sont et mineurs et non
accompagnés ils sont dans les mains de
trafiquant d'êtres humains les les la
France ne peut pas être les recelleurs
de ces trafiquants d'êtres humains alors
au détriment de l'enfance en danger
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui puisque
tous les départements disent on n peut
plus la ze déborde alors Valérie Boyer
le principe de cette émission c'est
qu'avec nos partenaires de la presse
régionale on regarde l'actualité dans
nos régions et là on va voir ce qui se
passe à Marseille on va retrouver nos
partenaires du journal La Marseillaise
avec Léo purguet président et directeur
éditorial du Journal bonjour Léo bonjour
Alors Léo vous souhtiez revenir sur la
la question du changement de mode de
scrutin aux élections municipales à
Paris et à Lyon et à Marseille un
changement souhaité par Emmanuel Macron
quelles pistes sont sur la table et
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
changerait
oui le président de la République a a
réaffirmé sa volonté de de réformer la
loi Paris lonmseille qui avait été
instaurée en son temps par le
ministreérieur qui était maire de
Marseille Gaston de fer euh la volonté
présidentielle c'est aligné le sououttin
de ces trois villes sur le mode de
soutin des autres communes de France
c'est-à-dire ne plus passer par des
élections par arrondissement ou par
secteurs municipaux comme à Marseille
évidemment ça va rebattre les cartes les
règles du jeu et je voulais savoir si
Valérie Boyer était favorable au
principe de cette réforme et si elle
avait des inquiétudes quant à ce
changement à un peu plus de 2 ans des
élections
municipales donc le principe de cette
réforme c'est un Marseillais une voix
est-ce que vous êtes favorable bah c'est
un petit peu alors moi déjà je vous
rappelle quelque chose aux personnes qui
nous regardent de la France entière
c'est qu'il y a une loi Paris
lyonmseille avec des situations très
différentes à Paris à Lyon comme à
Marseille Marseille c'est une ville
immense pour que c'est une ville qui a
la taille d'un département pour que les
Français qui nous écoutent se rendent
compte Marseille ça va de l'aéroport
d'orli l'aéroport de roiss Paris Paris
Paris euh vous parlez de Marseille ou
Paris je parle de de Marseille mais pour
situer la taille de Marseille je dis que
ça va de l'aéroport de la taille ça va
de l'aéroport d'Orly à l'aéroport de
Roissy et de du bois de Boulogne au bois
de Vincenne donc on voit bien
l'immensité de la ville c'est la raison
pour laquelle les arrondissements les
quartiers les S un villages de Marseille
ont une importance particulière c'est le
premier point le deuxème point je dois
dire qu'aujourd'hui si à Marseille nous
avons la nupese Marseillaise euh qui est
au gouvernement après le switch de
Madame Rubby Rola monsieur paayant dans
des voilà un peu bizarre c'est nous le
devons en grande partie à Emmanuel
Macron puisque le scrutin qui est le qui
est le nôre jusqu'à présent a permis au
candidat d'Emmanuel Macron de se
maintenir dans un arrondissement avec
des élections de maire de secteur de se
maintenir dans un arrondissement alors
qu'il avait été battu dans tous les
autres pour faire échouer madame vassal
donc et sa liste donc un moment donné il
faut savoir ce que l'on veut or
aujourd'hui dans ce scrutin qu'est-ce
qu'on veut est-ce qu'on veut plus de
démocratie plus de proximité qu'est-ce
qu' va y avoir dans dans ce
scrutin vous savez c'est beaucoup plus
facile de faire une liste unique que
d'avoir des listes par arrondissement
donc moi j'attends de voir ce qu'il y a
dans ce scrutin mais je vous avoue que
je suis lassée du en même temps et des
tripatouillage de la macronie dans tous
les domaines et de la confusion que ça
entraîne dans les esprits l purg vous
souhaitez réagir ben oui j'ai j'ai pas
bien compris si vous étiez favorable à
ce principe est-ce que est-ce que vous
considérez que ça va faire reculer la
proximité ou est-ce que vous considérez
que bien dans ces conditions là
finalement vous auriez emporté avec les
listes vassal la mairie la dernière fois
euh oui déjà mais aujourd'hui on n pas
de problème de de démocratie d'ailleurs
l'alternance à Paris lion ou Marseille
l'alternance a pu avoir lieu il y a une
proximité qui est organisée qui pourrait
être amélioré qui a toujours été on a
toujours promis l'amélioration de la
proximité moi j'attends de voir ce qu'il
y a dans ce texte pour voir ce qu'il en
est mais bon on voit bien qu'il y a une
sorte de panique en macronie pour
pouvoir une fois qu'Emmanuel Macron ne
sera plus président de la République
pour pouvoir s'enraciner c'est quand
même un des gros problèmes des
macronistes c'est de d'avoir échoué à
tous les scrutins locaux et aujourd'hui
ils veulent tripatouiller pour pouvoir y
parvenir et justement il nous reste 20
secondes Valérie Boyer est-ce que
l'objectif pour Emmanuel Macron ce n'est
pas de gagner Paris avec comme candidate
Rachid adati dans une éventuelle
alliance majorité présidentielle etr ce
serait souhaitable bah écoutez on verra
ce qu'il en est mais je ne suis pas
certaine que l'entrée au gouvernement de
Rachid adati lui facilite la tâche pour
gagner Paris bien au contraire et que ce
mode de scrutin qui je vais être rapide
c'est beaucoup plus facile de faire une
seule liste que de faire des listes par
arrondissement donc quand on provoque
les gens quand on les met dans une
situation avec des prises de guerre ça
s'appelle pas une une union hein ça
s'appelle un holdup c'est pas la même
chose et ce sera le bout de la fin merci
beaucoup Léo purget d'être passer dans
cette émission on regarde la Une de La
Marseillaise consacrée à la crise
agricole avec ce titre de la colère et
des larmes merci Valérie Boyer d'avoir
été notre sénatrice du jour